good to see Steve Levy worked with
leaves for a long time there at the
mothership now he's a big voice on
college football and also he's the lead
voice on the XF he'll give you the
official introduction here SportsCenter
anchor
are you still SportsCenter anchor I did
show this month okay
that's your street continues college
football
NHL XFL play-by-play in the XFL these
season kicks off on Saturday at 2 p.m.
Eastern on ABC
it's a this Seattle dragon just faced
the DC defenders you're there with Greg
McElroy yeah and Tom luginbill and Diana
Rossini when the dragons and defenders
get together there roll out the records
there are no records and throw out the
record yeah ok
so how do you approach this if I said
you're gonna do LSU against Georgia yeah
or are you gonna do the Dragons against
the defenders different oh not which
what I'd prefer no no okay
it's entirely different I think there's
less focused Dan on the actual players
themselves and more on how different the
game and the broadcast will be race
plane so there's gonna be a lot of
voices there's gonna be a lot so we a
for you just mentioned your voices on
television and there will be you know
five or six other voices constantly
throughout the broadcast so two players
on each team will be miked the entire
game that's pretty standard Farrow we
see that all time but the offensive
coordinator the play callers head coach
ROC he will be Mike and available for us
at all times so in the NFL right the
coordinator talks to the quarterbacks
helmet that cuts off at 15 seconds on
the play clock it will not cut off in
the XFL okay and it will be available to
our audience at all times now the
producer and director will decide when
it comes in
in addition that play caller will speak
to all skill position players so what
that does is it almost eliminates
Huddle's all together you could run a
long pattern and complete pass coming
back at the next play and bam and go so
we'll hear a lot of terminology and and
again that that pot will be all
been at all times to be up to the
director decide how much it airs but we
would be capable of taking that the
entire game and that could be really
interesting and again it doesn't cut off
in the XFL conceivably Dan you could
have the coordinators saying in the
quarterbacks helmet look left he's open
I don't think of that level but but so
that's the communication and the essence
of that is really to speed things up
they're gonna go fast there are tweaks
to the rules which are different
25-second play clock instead of 40 for
example but this is about the technology
this is abouting doing a football game
differently experimentation that's what
I mean by it's more about that I think
then the players to begin look the
players got to be good quarterbacks got
to be able to hit the open receiver
receivers got to be able to make the
catch you know there's got to be good
fundamental football and listen you've
heard of all the head coaches you've
heard of all the coordinators and you've
heard about you know maybe 20-30 percent
of the players of this first game I've
gone through the notes about 80 percent
of the guys have had at least a cup of
coffee in the NFL okay all training
training camp
I'll practice squad so they just you
know on the bubble or mr. cut whatever
and here's an opportunity this is a
great way to extend their dream either
get back to the NFL or put some good
tape out there with good coaching and
get into the end the goal is to be the
Developmental League with the NFL you
know they haven't said that but I
believe the NFL is in favor this is this
is a win for everyone who loves football
and that's the slogan for the XFL for
the love of football but if you're the
NFL how could you not love this that
there will be tons of NFL scouts at all
of these games there's no question they
went to the training camps there will be
like I said a lot of NFL players who
were on the bubble and missed the cut so
and it's the perfect window right Dan
it's you know it's it's the week after
the Super Bowl
runs through the NFL Draft the exact
window when there is no football
other than off you know on the
conversation are you embracing gambling
yes I think that will be up to the
individual but the league is said they
would like it we are gonna have the
point spread and the over/under on the
score bug constantly now what do you
mean it's up to the individual you know
they've said if we want to talk about it
I'll talk about they
like us too and then it'll be the you
know the comfort level look we do that
in the fourth quarter anyway right
you know oh that's an important field
well to some people and the point spread
can be helpful at a lot of ways because
look we don't know a lot about these
teams so I'd like to know going in
whoo-hoo Vegas might think is a heavy
favorite
you know who's expected to win this game
should it be a high-scoring game or a
low-scoring game but they're gonna do
fantasy football to look everything
that's good about football they're gonna
try to bring to the XFL why not there's
a fantasy football XFL course raft of
course give me the top five players five
three so this is interesting to me dan
the quarterbacks will get paid now
roughly here we'll roughly get paid ten
times
what everybody else gets paid all right
think about that for a second they did
that to ensure you get good quarterbacks
because you need a good quarterback play
but but what does that mean ten times
ten times a thousand is ten thousand
okay so some quarterbacks and it's not I
don't love this public night so where
are they gonna get half a million bucks
no okay that real money okay okay but
regular players you know linebackers are
gonna get 50 grand for the season okay
okay so that's the ten times so when Ben
Roethlisberger went down a week to for
the Steelers their first call was to
Landry Jones you know he was tied up
signed to an XML contract and locked in
so he you know he's probably the biggest
name Landry Jones
Cardale Jones Cardale Jones from Ohio
State national championship so there are
guys like Emory
I think I dreamt about the Chiefs I was
gonna say I thought you drafted him and
you're famous now yeah later today
and so Landry Jones is playing for his
old coach Bob Stoops from Oklahoma so
there's some geographical smartness
right they put them in Texas near
Oklahoma's you know yeah that's right
next noon there's a ball spotter they
ball spotted yeah it's part of the new
nuances you need more on there yeah like
is that don't leave you hanging on that
so there's not like a ball girl what for
it's fair question no there will be an
extra official on the field and they
cannot throw a flag the only official
cannot throw a flag they are there to
spot the football that's
their only job oh why do we need this
it's to speed up the game so Dan get
this and this is where it gets a little
wacky on the rules and people by the
wall what's going on here so on an
incomplete pass or a run out of bounds
outside of two minutes they're gonna
spot the ball and go like you know it's
not the normal stoppage you know like in
the NFL again it's in essence speed more
snaps how long are the games supposed to
last that's a great question to man we
could see two and a half our games are
windows three hours so you'll want to
stay tuned for the postgame [ __ ] these
games could be two and a half hours and
if we ever get to an overtime that'll be
cool too they're gonna do like a
shootout overtime single play five
offensive plays but alternating each
team your offense and defense gonna run
on the field one snap boom then they got
a run off and then the other side comes
give me the rule you think the NFL or
that whatever the gadget will adopt if
you were guessing so the coolest thing
we're the coolest rule to add an is the
nine point play in essence okay so
you're making here we go so the nine
point plan there's no extra point there
our field goals but there's no
possibility of kicking an extra point
okay so you score a touchdown that's
worth six still we're good there
and then the coach has the decision you
can run a play from the two for one
point you can run a play from the five
for two points you're I'm going here and
you can run a play from the ten worth
three points therefore Dan down 18 late
you're a two score game you're not going
anywhere but what about the rule of no
helmets in overtime is that no pants
over time there are no cheerleaders
there are no coin flight Vince McMahon
has no cheerleaders that might be the
biggest event on the old excess amount
yeah ten minute half time dance
they might not even leave the field I
mean they're gonna go go go
you should crack a beer like during the
game that would be good yeah for you
like if you have a beer sponsor and just
right let's all brought to you by yeah
Budweiser king of beers yeah that's
something like that all right bring it
up yep
you fired up about art I think so I
think I think you need to adopt a team
hmm as you look at the map so they're
very excited in st. Louis for example
Dan
they got ripped off they lost their Rams
right yeah no I mean they're really
still they're still hang and they should
be but the Kroenke people they're
they're they're cranky about that cranky
my chronic right okay my gun they've
sold I think they're gonna have thirty
thousand at their home opener and
they're playing in the big stadium
Seattle's done very well they might have
30,000 for their home opener in the big
stadium why didn't you bring in a
football yeah that was my mistake I
noticed that when you have every
everything yes hey XFL people at XFL
said DPS and stuff best uniform in the
XFL is who the Vipers of Tampa the Tampa
Bay Vipers and they'll play in Raymond
James they got the gold and yellow thing
going on the only thing I dislike it
like it changed one thing okay they've
got an LA franchise they got New York in
LA the LA wild
yeah it's that awful and it's not like a
movie it was Goldie Hawn you guys are
talking about sports movie on that
goldie Hawn's the coach the mom in that
rough neighborhood yeah be a little more
creative
you got the battle Hawks in st. Louis
Dan but don't do the decent defenders
have to be a good defensive team you
would think so they apep Hamilton who
was the former Michigan offensive
coordinator and they have Cornell Jones
two o'clock Eastern on ABC ABC every
Saturday and that was that was the other
difference Stan that's why I think this
is gonna certainly make it through one
season it's supposed to be a f4 one in
the middle yeah deep pockets of Vince
okay and the television partnership
that's the key I think the AAF put put
the first game on CBS the big CBS and
then they went away they went to other
affiliates we're gonna be on ABC and
ESPN we're not gonna be on the ODE show
like this has the full backing of our
company
your former company yeah yeah so you're
still doing sports centers huh couple
did a couple to Super Bowl you remember
your first Sports Center yes I do
call Ravich was Co active gives me the
big introduction rabi been like three
months before me like not a long time
he's in veteran right so yeah actually
load the story so back in those days did
a two-shot and lead in you look down and
boom and go to your one shot which I'm
gonna do anymore of course I never
turned cameras so I did my usual 35
second lead straight ahead on a two-shot
without referencing revenues to my left
and the legendary producer Mike
McQuaid's in my ears it turn left
II look left I'm so nervous I stared on
the two-shot camera the entire time
please turn left it's like the XFL
coordinator in the quarterbacks helmet
turn left he's open yeah so did you have
a tough SportsCenter as far as the topic
you know I mentioned when Jim Valvano
died yeah and he had said to me before
he died would you put a good picture of
me over your shoulder so he's asking me
that the last time I see him it he has
been and then when he died that's all I
said look we got to put a great picture
over my shoulder the other one was when
the Cleveland Indians pitchers died in
the boating accident spring training
yeah those were tough I was on the air
you guys laugh to help me on the names
the Yankees relief pitcher was flying
the plane into Manhattan Cory Lidle
is that right is that his name poling
Cory Lidle Lidl II could be me it was
the Indians before then maybe Yankees I
can't man I want to being on
SportsCenter and you know you just don't
know how to handle that you're not
you're not ready for that I'm I'm in
Manhattan that day yeah and I heard more
fire trucks than a police sirens then
I've ever heard in my life at the same
time and I said something tragic
happened turn on the TV and I'm about
five blocks away right where he flew
into the building yep
now those are those are brutal days and
so the kobe bryant obviously recently
but we all we all banded together one
Muhammad Muhammad Ali passed away
you sort of know that one's coming yeah
right cuz you know old age and and that
kind of thing but I had Magic Johnson
when he I had to throw out to the
coverage of magic announcing that he was
HIV positive everybody remembers that
and we got a call from Dick Schaap the
legendary Dick Schaap then he called the
assignment desk and he said Magic's
retiring we're like why would magic
retire right and then all of a sudden I
was told get down on this set throw it
out to the press conference and then you
know bring it back and you throw it out
there and who knew about HIV right at
the time or how much did we know now
magic is gonna retire and you're you try
to wrap your head around that so when
you throw to the presser you don't know
why still at that point we weren't sure
right I all I know is that Dick Schaap
had called the assignment desk and he
was working for us and he said magics
gonna retire yeah magics gonna retire
and then was like get down to the set
you know they're holding a press
conference and I'm you know you're
racing down there and you're like you
throw it out there and you're not quite
sure what you're gonna get right and you
got it and then you're like oh my god
how do you process this right how do you
come out of that yeah you do and they're
hours some you know perspective on that
listen hey that's what we are in the
money by the way really you know if it's
the it's ever just standard night and
you're reading off the teleprompter and
doing regular highlights and you know a
lot of people can do that Dan but you
know when a big story breaks like that
and how you handle it that's the
expertise and and you're gonna earn your
money this weekend we're gonna be fired
up about it Dan I'm particularly a close
game you are mister ex-nfl I'm gonna try
it's fun it's it's pro football it it is
football and it's something to be on the
ground floor they're really like not
recognizing 2001 at all as if it if it
never happened like statistically or and
they want to the XFL really wants to
distance themselves so those stats don't
still hold up is he hate me rushing
stats still that's the one question I
get is he hate me still playing is he
playing on Saturday he's at rod smart
yeah rod smart yeah he's not he's not
playing right I don't believe so we have
some older players will be tuning in
Satur that did not sound like a real
tuning in
I'm gonna do a drive-by okay I'm gonna
do a drive-by yeah I think people will
be curious right curious you it's about
here's something yeah if you do this on
Saturday yeah I will direct my audience
to make sure I will marshal my audience
to watch the show okay watch the game
what do I have to do just say the words
passion bucket passion bucket that's it
done okay anything harder no no it's
gonna say you know you could have
dropped in McLovin but that might be a
little bit tougher I just think a you
know nice nice you know if your football
passion bucket is not full then we have
something for you today might be the
first words out of my before Dianna
Rossini gets introduced you're gonna say
passion buckets yeah you're gonna
welcome us on the air with that fill up
your passion strap yourself in and ready
to go
the 2020 XFL season kicks off Saturday
at 2:00 p.m. Eastern if you wanted to
see Cardale Jones again you get a chance
seattle dragon's face Cardale Jones and
the DC defend yeah they do
yeah great to see you leaves thanks for
having the good luck buddy for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]